es una lista de
7.754 nombres niños que las autoridades
ucranianas reclaman a las de Moscú
menores de edad que se quedaron en los
territorios conquistados por las fuerzas
del kremlin y desplazados algunas veces
a Rusia aquí la historia de dos de estos
destinos
cosachalopan un pueblo ocupado por los
rusos en febrero y reconquistado por
Ucrania hace dos semanas allí viven Yuri
Tatiana y su hija de la que no tienen
noticias
a finales de agosto polina se montó en
un bus que tenía Rusia como destino con
otros 13 niños un viaje organizado por
la alcaldía pero rusa
al lado del bus le dimos un beso y un
abrazo le dije que disfrutará
dicho la alcaldía llevaba a los niños a
Campos vacacionales en el mar Negro
convenció a sus padres de confiar a
polina porque la ciudad estaba siendo
bombardeada
aceptamos para que nuestra hija pudiera
estar segura un niño murió en nuestra
calle y una mujer también pensábamos que
estábamos haciendo lo correcto
los niños tenían que volver a mediados
de septiembre pero con la reconquista
del pueblo la frontera con Rusia se
volvió a cerrar
Natalia Met la vecina también envió a su
hija al campo vacacional y tiene miedo
de que los rusos se nieguen a devolverle
a su hija
Cómo se llama Karina tiene 13 años
la madre nos muestra el periódico
prorruso que promociona el campo
vacacional en el mar Negro un periódico
de propaganda
piensa que los rusos quieren quedarse
con los niños
Sí sí sé que le dan papeles rusos a las
familias ucranianas para que se queden
les dicen que Ucrania no los quiere más
les Proponen residencias si voy no puedo
volver con mi hija
Natalia no ha hablado con su hija desde
que se fue la alcaldía nunca entregó la
dirección del campo de verano ni tampoco
su número de teléfono
no puedo hablarle no puedo llamarla no
puedo decirle vamos a ir a buscarte
espera un poco tengo miedo de que piense
que la abandonamos
La angustia y un sentimiento de culpa
pesan sobre esta madre
la policía ucraniana fue visitar a la
familia de polina y Karina para escuchar
sus relatos y reclamar el regreso de los
niños
desde que comenzó la guerra 56 menores
de edad han podido ser repatriados de
territorios ocupados o de Rusia